also hier haben wir das schöne produkt
einer sg 700 new upgrade single duell
klarer bleibtreu in gravity und so
weiter diese leute wir gehen mal kurz
noch draußen ja das muss ich unbedingt
mal draußen testen und dann gebe ich
mich erst zufrieden er höher geht nicht
also höher geht nicht aber gebt euch das
mal werde ich wohl zu verarschen
also finger wirklich richtig richtig
traurig kurzes tommy bevor dieses video
losgeht eigentlich sollte ein video
kommt zu einem ipad was ich auf ruhig
gestellt habt also das sollte breite
kommen mann ich bin der größte vogel
sachen jetzt bitte nicht dass hier nur
die tastatur drin ist ich habe
verschiedene technik sachen bestellt wie
dieses ipad eine drohne um dies dann
jetzt heute halt schon geht in
camcordern der überwachungskamera alles
für ziemlich wenig geld wobei dieses
ipad
am teuersten war film 30 euro gekostet
und die haben mich so was von verrat ich
habe auch natürlich man kann es merken
aber es ist schon schwierig ich wollte
dieses fähigkeit mit haben und was habe
ich bekommen eine facchin tastatur bei
der das wichtigste fehlt ich meinen 35
euro für seine tastatur
also bitte jetzt werden natürlich einige
sagen ja alex was denkst du denn längst
im film 30 uhr gibt es das auch noch mit
ipad hier oder mit diesem pack dinge ich
habe auch schon handys für 30 euro
kommen deswegen bin ich wirklich davon
ausgegangen darum ist jetzt leider
erstmalig schade
leute ich habe gar kein problem also
eigentlich bin ich schon ziemlich
niedergeschlagen habe und würde
natürlich lieber das jetzt erst mal
machen aber ich habe noch was gestellt
und zwar eine flugdrohne wobei ich
gerade sagen muss ich bin jetzt wirklich
nicht sicher ob er überhaupt so eine
rolle drin ist also hier haben wir das
schöne produkt einer sg 700 new upgrade
single dollar
gravity und so weiter das ganze hat mich
27 euro gekostet wenn man hier mal
schaut so soll die drohne aussehen ich
meinen 27 euro dafür ist schon echt sehr
sehr wenig bevor wir uns jetzt
allerdings weiter mit irgendwelchen
daten befassen muss ich das erste mal
auspacken nachher ist da wirklich nur
eine kamera für dieses ding drin oder
sonstwas wollen das finde ich ja so
aggressiv machen also wir checken das
jetzt erst mal aus das hier ist das
paket
ich muss schon sagen es ist echt gleich
leute hier kann man das schon sehen
wir haben eine kleine drohne hier drin
mit fernbedienung
ich muss jetzt über sagen ich bin
eigentlich positiv überrascht das sieht
echt gut aus hier sind die rotor ich
kann mich damit drohen eigentlich selber
ganz gut auch ich habe eine magic frau
die sich ein bisschen ähnlich aus wie
die magic er ich kann euch hier mal ein
foto einblenden die mehrweg frau die ich
habe und auch die mehrweg er hier liegen
allerdings preislich bei dem 40 fahren
von diesem jahr die kosten ungefähr so
um die 1000 euro
deswegen bin ich wirklich mal gespannt
was die rotoren hier haben wir eine
fernsteuerung also so sieht die
fernsteuerung aus hier einmal für video
hier mithilfe die drohne wahrscheinlich
ab und hier kann man danach nach
ausflügen zur seite zur anderen seite
oder nach hinten die kann sogar
vielleicht automatisch zurück kommen
wobei mich das echt wundern würde und
das wichtigste kommt jetzt das hier ist
die drohne im sieht gar nicht mal
schlecht aus von der qualität ist sogar
wirklich mit einer kamera ja also ich
bin wirklich mal gespannt wie das
funktionieren soll
leute ich nehme alles zurück doch nicht
mit kamera die kamera hier drin vorne
fehlt aber das ist ja gar nicht mal so
schlimm ich mein wenn das ding überhaupt
fliegt und dann auch gut fliegt keine
ahnung wie schnell fliegt das würde mich
schon extrem wundert auch die ist auch
schon an
ja so also die drohne geht schon mal
direkt an das finde ich echt cool
ich würde sagen ich setze mich jetzt
erstmal mit dem ganzen zeug ein bisschen
auseinander lesen die beschreibung durch
und das einzige was wir dann gleich noch
dann ist sie mal zum fliegen zu bringen
ich hoffe das geht auch also ich legte
es jetzt erstmal hier zur seite also das
ding wohl wirklich schon aufgekauft wir
haben 1362 bewertungen das ist ja
wirklich gut qualität von plastik nicht
sehr gut aber für das geld perfekt super
schnelle lieferung artikel ist ob
kleiner nachteil die videos müssen nach
aufnahme umgewandelt werden in mp4
problem bei mir ich habe ja keine kamera
ich glaube das liegt daran weil ich die
kamera nicht mit bestellt habe
anscheinend warum auch immer
da hätte ich eigentlich machen können
kostet alles das gleiche gut aber so ist
das deswegen wenn ihr euch bestellen
wollten mit kamera könnte machen gar
kein problem aber bestellt die bitte
auch erst wenn ich sage okay ist gut die
soll sogar wirklich mit einem handy
gesteuert werden also ich muss mir
gleich wahrscheinlich bis herunter laden
und ja dass damit der ohne verbinden
also wenn das ding der kamera hat gibt
es sogar nicht nur ein modus sondern
verschiedene wenn man sein handy
verbundenheit geht das halt über gps
dann kann die automatisch folgen und so
weiter also zählt ja hier aber gut damit
würde ich mich jetzt gleich befassen uns
geht es heute darum fliegt das ding und
lohnt sich das für 27 euro
ich muss sagen dass man für so wenig
geld sowas bekommt also der erste
eindruck ist schon mal gut wir testen
das jetzt und ich nehme euch mit jetzt
musste ich gerade noch extra batterien
kaufen für die fernbedienung dieser
automatisch an angegangen blinkt hier
rot und geht jetzt gar nicht mehr raus
also ich glaube in den anderen aus
schalter gibt es hier gar nicht man muss
dann wenn schon die batterien wieder
rausnehmen und was ich leider bis jetzt
auch noch nicht gefunden habt irgendwo
sollte man sein handy anschließen können
ein anschluss dafür wie allerdings noch
nicht gefunden
und es gibt auch keine apple app store
für diese drohne deswegen hoffe ich mal
sich liegt auch so leute wie so habe ich
dass er sich auch schon und plötzlich
fängt dieses ding anzubieten
oh mann ich glaube das ist jetzt kaputt
also leute wir machen noch mal kurz hier
drinnen im test weil das geht schon
keine ahnung wie es zustande kommt
technisch aus den gibt abnehmen
hh
vorne hat mich das soll euch folgendes
problem irgendwas ist jetzt gerade
abgeflogen und es hinzu und die wand ist
leicht beschädigt aber nicht ich habe
jetzt nur dass die hier agiert hat
[Musik]
also dieses ding letztlich überhaupt
nicht was ihnen bleibt das ist jetzt der
geflogen
ich verstehe die leute wir gehen mal
kurz nach draußen ja das muss ich
unbedingt noch mal draußen testen und
dann werde ich mich erst zufrieden so
leute ich bin jetzt hier in den wald
gegangen hier ist weg so eine große
grünfläche wo ich das man machen kann
weil das ist ganz wichtig für so teile
ich weiß jetzt nicht ob es bei der auch
schon so ist ich glaube die region oder
250 gramm
weil es noch mal was anderes das ist in
vielen versicherungen schon mit drin
aber eigentlich braucht man dafür
wirklich für fluggenehmigung und eine
versicherung und blablabla deswegen
kauft euch auf keinen fall so ein teil
und fliegt damit über die stadt oder so
dass es ganz wichtig aber hier zum
beispiel ist alles schön grün und keiner
im weg hier kann ich glaube ich in ruhe
mal kurz fliegen wollen das problem ist
dann auch wenn die so unkontrolliert
fliegt ich habe keine ahnung was damit
los ist aber dass er unberechenbar so
jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt wie
hoch die fliegt und wie weit so also ja
mal sehen also ich habe leider kein
kameramann dabei aber so an ist sie
schon mal
also leute da oben also man muss
wirklich sagen die fliegt sogar echt
ganz gut guck mal da oben ist ich steuer
die jetzt mal einfach nach oben
mal gucken wie husten ist ja wirklich
krass alter versuche für so wenig geld
so ein ding ja also die safe schon 50
meter hoch junge hier da oben wirklich
heftig höher geht nicht also höher geht
nicht aber gebt euch das mal ich weiß
gar nicht ob ihr die überhaupt auf der
kamera sieht jetzt drücke ich mal hier
auf kritik
und die kommt sogar hierhin zurück oder
wohin geht
komm runter kommen einfach nur geradeaus
runter mehr will ich gar nicht
also hier ist die falsche richtung so
also ich muss wirklich sagen das hätte
ich echt nicht gedacht dass das geht ich
meine die steuerung von dem teil ist
echt nicht wirklich gut aber die
verbindung was auch immer hier drin
steckt für technik in diesem kleinen
dingen das liegt echt gar nicht das ist
schon krass nicht mal die wahl bestimmt
grad auf 70 meter ich habe keine ahnung
ob die noch sehen konnte also auf jeden
fall nicht schlecht
ich würde sagen ich fahre jetzt nach
hause scheint das video das war s dann
an dieser stelle wenn es euch gefallen
hat und ihr noch mehr so produkttest
sehen wollt gibt auf jeden fall noch
nach oben
ich hasse es immer wenn menschen mich
dumm angemacht auch hier ein typ mit der
kamera mit dabei
ansonsten sehen wir uns am sonntag
wieder und ja cool ist teil also fazit
überrascht gut rein